no i'm going i'm going into space before
i die that is 100
i'm waiting for the i i need like it's
my salary
and
contact comes down you've got the
confidence i really want to i ain't got
that kind of confidence
i'm like i would really like to be cheap
you think they're great i think by the
way
but like going out of the atmosphere for
20 minutes yeah for sure
well i have been on a zero g flight and
that's not quite the same
it's just a cool thing that i did that
cost 12 grand thankfully
i got that i got the same kind of invite
and i didn't take it and i've regretted
it ever since
very cool i was on a zero g flight for a
second but that's just because
it's called landing well no we like we
dropped really quickly and i was like oh
that's what it feels like
that's my i don't like roller coasters
oh and i don't i don't for that specific
reason
i hate that that that that feeling
hate it the dropping feeling yeah
skydiving love because you never get the
feeling of dropping
other than the earth racing towards you
well you're dropping the whole time but
it doesn't feel like you're dropping
because you start out already moving at
9.8 meters per second per second
hmm
for the second second second square um i
think we need two seconds
for a second troy it's an acceleration
you're absolutely right that would be a
square apologies
sorry my my nerdy fuck-up programmer i
was going to say yeah mike
i'm amazed i'm amazed that one's right
it's an accelerating value it would be a
square you're absolutely right
exposed slightly it was it was lost in
the maelstrom there
i felt like it was quite good he spoke
about cancer
it was that because because what you
what you said
i once had a conversation um
with uh with a friend of mine and he was
saying we were talking about you know
the ideal ways to die
and it was like if you if you know you
have a terminal disease
and and you're like your numbers up soon
and you would rather end on your own
terms what what do you
do and so i say well you know
i think the the contact um
get blasted in a one-way trip into space
is probably my
my go-to but there's something to be
said about the idea of the
adrenaline rush of like you know
leaping off the edge of the grand canyon
or something so it was like why not
combine the two that one i i've thought
about this
mine's definitely heroin overdose that's
what if i'm you know
going out bliss out just hard on the
herald all the way to the wall
yeah um but i think
the issue with like a jumping off a
building or a falling off a uh canyon
is that uh the adrenaline rush [ __ ]
show
the adrenaline rush i love it that you
would like
i'm super compelled i'm like this is i
think you would regret it as you're
falling
but that's the beauty of it there's no
you it's too bad
but i don't want my losses when i'm
trying to go out to be
[ __ ] i should respond yeah you're
fighting too
many like pre-programmed yeah
survivalist things
yeah yeah so you're having like a
biological reaction to fear at that
point which is not a fun i imagine it's
not a fun way to go yeah and it's like
you can't drown yourself
like your body at one point will take
over and go you're stupid we're gonna do
whatever we can to survive
yeah i imagine that would be very hard
well anyway i
i think i think combining the two i
think getting blasted into space
on a collision course with like mars
would be
would be the the ultimate combination of
the two
go mike bethel i'm just thinking like if
one were to set up a trampoline at the
bottom of the grand canyon could one
combine the two
so you go down and then you shoot up and
hit an escape velocity
your legs would break the minute you
fell into it you just wouldn't but i was
like
i think the science checks out i really
do i think shakes out
in my physics class i was like i have a
question the teacher was like yes i said
talking about falling everything she's
like yes i said so if i was falling on a
rock
she goes right and i said the last
moment i jumped
up or stepped off to the side is like
would i not make it and she was like
why would you think that it's like
because there's a certain coyote
that someone supposed to be able to do
that there's a whole i just want to know
there was a whole mythbusters about
this the variation on this of jumping in
a falling elevator
yeah and and showing that you know
pushing off of again
pushing off of a thing accelerating at
that speed does not take away the fact
that you're also still
accelerating at that speed yeah i uh i i
thank you for solving that mystery you
know
you have like friends who are pretty
dumb but entertainingly dumb
hey
there's a guy i know who who uh
intentionally does it because it's funny
but with trains like every time he's on
a train
he'll jump and he'll be like i just
don't understand why i don't move back
when the train's moving forward
he'll do it every single time people are
like what are you trying to do but then
i also understand if you were a kid
why that logically wouldn't make sense
you'd be like but i should be staying
still and the train should be moving
even though you are moving this
train this is einstein's thing it's like
you can't you're not
um uh you couldn't jump off that and
move faster than it
like the whole right should i pull this
should i bring this to video game should
i bring this home because
interestingly what we're describing here
is something that game designers have to
deal with all the time
because you understand that if you jump
on a train
you're not going to fly backwards
because the train's moving
but that's because of a step in your
brain which is intellectualizing the
problem
and your your immediate reaction would
be no things go where they where
things stay where they are and then your
knowledge and your intelligence
takes over from your intuition and and
gives you the right answer the problem
in game design often we're genuinely
having conversations about
okay what's what's the child-like
response to this problem and you're
often playing to that rather than the
intellectual because you don't want the
player when the
i'm trying to think of an example of
this from a game but like when you
reload a gun
most games when you reload a gun it
takes the five bullets that are in the
chamber and adds on
as many bullets as needed but you lose
the bullets that were in the gun right
because your immediate kind of intuitive
understanding of reload gun
is i'm going to put some more bullets in
this gun if you think about it for a
second you're like no i'd have to remove
a clip and put another one in and you're
going to lose that
i always appreciate it when every now
and again i play a first person shooter
that actually makes you lose the bullets
that you were holding if you reload
prematurely and i'm like ah
somebody actually when we look exactly
but when we look and john wick did that
as well i think perfect when you look at
that
yeah when you look at play test data
though often you find
people say in youtube comments
that they want the intellectual correct
thing but actually when they're playing
the thing they enjoy and the thing they
respond well to
is the kind of the the kind of the less
intellectual eyes because you're in the
flow you're enjoying a game
so it's interesting that idea of the
kind of child-like
this feels like it should work this way
um is something that comes up so much in
game design because you often have to
design to that
rather than the reality and then work
out a way to frame that so that
when you when you think about it for a
second you don't think it's stupid um
and that's procedurally generated and
that's procedurally generated content
i've been waiting mike is it also
you're like soon soon shut up
mike is it also fair to say that that um
it is when when designing games
a lot of our intuited
understanding of the world you have to
kind of step
through as part of the design process
because a a game being made from scratch
won't have a lot of the built-in
assumptions like in our train example
if i have a character like say it's a 2d
side scrolling game and there's a
train like from a programming standpoint
the
the software does not have the built-in
knowledge of physics unless you're you
know
buying into something that already has
that baked in you know pre
pre-made engine or something uh because
generally the screen's not moving the
world is
yeah well that's a separate that's
actually a separate that's like the
cheap but what i what i
do you mean you have to literally
program it but i mean like real world
stuff doesn't exist unless you put it
into the simulation
yeah like physics don't just inherently
belong in the game yeah yeah exactly
that was that was
that is very neither should they you
don't know but it's really weird to
think about that it's like you have to
make all the physics they don't they
aren't just
there that is an odd thing to think
about and you have to make what you
think you don't
want physics you don't want real world
physics in your games
real world physics you don't i'm telling
you all you want
i'm telling you that's procedural
generation is it like the rate like the
running rate like we did this thing
on second son is like if you actually
mapped how fast delson was running it's
like
usually old man yeah yeah stupid
yeah but it's covering too much ground
it's the speed so
literally like if you've got a game with
any kind of interactive physics you're
probably running that half speed
so an object would fall at half the
speed it would in the real world
because for you to have reaction time
interaction with those objects
you need to be able to see those things
happen too fast in the real world
the reason you don't have lightning
reflexes in real life
but you have them in games is because
games are often running the world a
little bit slower
terrible reflexes but thank you for
achieving the best of me
but what if that's also because we have
kind of uh we have to deal
i'm pulling on this interface right that
says
yeah this you you have to there's
there's a there's too many factors
at play that are preventing me from
doing that does that change
even incrementally if it's vr
changes so i can i can go do you want my
do you want my brains are [ __ ]
fact of the day in a nice bowl and just
eat it like okay so it's my favorite
here's my favorite fact i found out in
the last like couple of days and i bored
my team
senseless with this earlier i can't wait
it's great set up
you've got i know troy will within
handy reach have a pair of sunglasses do
you have a pair of sunglasses
don't they're all about genuinely
shocked okay
so if you try i'm gonna okay alarm is
gonna be the one then that has the
what moment wait wait yes i do oh she
comes back with a full beard and a hat
too if you
put if you put one sunglasses lens
on on your right eye alarm put it over
your if you can like
angle them so just over your right eye
yeah it's it's weird you don't have to
hold it for a while there but yeah
so if you put that over your right eye
and you watch footage
of like a basically stuff moving left to
right
like a like a view out a train window
i just know it's trying it's glorious
if you watch moving footage that footage
will appear three-dimensional to you
yeah so
your hand just did that can you do that
to your hand again so if i move my hand
right to left
it becomes 3d right yeah it does
or at least it looks like i'm looking
through a 3d uh
camera a 3d movie yeah yeah yeah let me
just tell you
that's three
oh it's a shame i was so close
that was so free so it'll work if you
want to do it later anyone who wants to
do this at home
i'm going to get there in a second so
what anyone who does at home do it with
high
the higher the frame rate footage the
better it looks yeah when it goes here i
can't see it
[Applause]
your brain takes longer to process
darker images
because there's less high contrast data
there so it takes your brain about 1
30th of a second
longer to to process an image if you're
in a dimly lit environment and if you're
in a bright environment wow
there's a lag there's basically like a
screen like i see someone in my team
mentioned earlier it's like crt and
with with fighting games you want to
play on old tvs is that the same thing
there is a controller lag in your brain
for
dimly lit stuff so what happens with
right to left movement only works on
things that are in motion
is that if it's in motion your right eye
is essentially
viewing the image one frame behind your
left eye
and therefore it's creating that
stereoscopic split on an object moving
left to right
no way if it's moving from left to right
you're right i forget if it's right to
left
right to left makes it feel like it's
coming towards you and left to right
makes you feel like it's going away
anyone at home can do this just
literally put sunglass on your right eye
and watch like footage of any parallaxy
thing happening out of the window
but isn't that basically the how the
physics of 3d glasses work anyway
because the
aren't like the one lens polarized
vertically the directionality of light
well it's what it is
but isn't that achieving the same exact
same idea different image in each eye
what's interesting here is that the
image on the screen so when i was moving
my hand back and forth and it looked
like my hand was 3d
coming out of the screen at lana it
didn't you didn't see like a ghosted
image on troy and austin's screen it
looks just like
normal video as good as my webcam ever
looks
that's the that's yeah sorry i'm being
really nerdy and boring but it is it's
an interesting thing about your brain so
wait to answer your question troy yes
adding a controller to your hands
adds in lag but even sitting and playing
a game on a dimly lit screen
will also introduce lag into your
feedback process
if this if your screen is too dark you
will
by definition have or if when you're
walking
in the street at night your your
reaction time is about 130 if less
because you're seeing an image from a
further back in time
humans are stupid but i mean at least we
filter out our own noses
at least we trick ourselves not to see
our noses i do know
with vr specifically troy that and i'm
sure i would have said this on the show
before because it's one of my favorite
facts
if you are playing a game in vr um
you will remember it as though it is a
real memory not as though it was a
memory you had of playing a game
because you know when you see something
that distinct
it's right in front of you there isn't
the room setting around you your brain
is just like yeah i went and did that
in resident evil 7 i've been to that
house you will remember layouts better
in vr
you'll remember virtually everything
better so you could be a
better at a video game if you played it
in vr for a while and then played it out
of vr in theory you would have a better
memory of the systems
that's really cool because your brain
doesn't go nah throw that away i was
just playing a stupid video game it goes
this half
i was the pilot i maybe i am the
squadron
and then you just remember that's scary
with horror games right that people
might if theoretically you could make a
game that would give someone like ptsd
that's right that's the first place
first place i went also like
you know the the idea of playing a game
like first thing i thought of was the
leaps of faith
in assassin's creed where it's like i i
picture you having like
yeah like a year of therapy to like get
over this
this traumatic
all of the murder that you did yeah i'm
not gonna say which but i've been
in a talk i've been like in a briefing
from one of the
one of the companies that makes vr
equipment
and literally that's a slide they
literally use uncharted as the example
they say please don't make uncharted
because we genuinely don't know yet
how much your experience like uncharted
in vr would mess with someone
if it was good enough i don't know if
it's genuinely something they're scared
of can you
you probably can and i'm just not
familiar with it but maybe one of you
does know um
can you get ptsd from something that is
not real
that's what i'm saying is if it if you
could short-circuit the part of your
brain as you say and make it feel like a
real location a real memory
maybe theoretically i don't know why
because memories are so
subconscious that seems a little bit
different like that's the same as the
why you get motion sickness in vr right
it's because your eyes think that what
you're seeing is real but your body
recognizes that you aren't moving so the
distance this is one of the points
this is one of the coolest facts that
mike bithell has ever shared with me
besides the fact that he has six toes on
one foot that's true
is seven on the other seven that's a
weird he just walks you over one
he's like a weird footballer like that
those are cool facts
um
if he uh if he walks long enough in a
straight line it does eventually become
a circle
yeah yeah yeah but like an elliptical
it's working that's true of anyone
walking around the earth if we're if we
uh particularly it's the fact that the
reason why
is because your body believes it's been
poisoned so it's it's
yeah this one the theories that is
fantastic
[Music]
is there any films have had the same
thing right like there's there's a
potential
um the impact that jaws had
sociologically for people
at the beach was was measurable yeah
right
um led to a spike in shark killing as
well
really i think i remember reading a
logical impact
ecological impact like more sharks were
killed as a result of
of the popular consciousness kind of
becoming aware of it's obviously not all
spielberg's fault
it's actually whose fault is it austin
to the viewers the best special effect
in that movie
there it is jaws
the shot's called jaws actually you know
what's funny about me you know what's
funny about
uh that's the family guy joke wait the
sequel is called jaws only according to
peter griffin
um i thought the shark's name was john's
yeah the the kid is in the sea called
yours too
obviously the funny jules ii
sharks have very boring naming
conventions my name is
patriot is my father that's a family
name
trying to get out from under his legacy
the funny thing the funny thing with
demoing the uh
the music on the piano is that back in
those days
you know nowadays we have computers
right that that you um
you mock up everything you can make
these pretty realistic uh
renderings before you ever hire any
musicians
and but in those days that was not the
case you basically had
it was a two-step process spielberg goes
over to john williams house
he plays around on the piano and and
says this is kind of what i'm thinking
and then it's like okay that seems like
maybe that that's on the right track
we'll see you in a month at the
recording session with you know the 90
piece orchestra so sure enough
john williams literally is all right
hear me out
[Music]
and spielberg laughed and was like no
but really
what are you planning and he was like
just trust me
and so he trusted him and and uh
won an oscar for it and and literally i
think
i think it's arguably the most iconic
piece of film music ever written
by anyone for any film there's only one
thing that i think can even
go toe-to-toe with it so justin
timberlake
i'm loving it oh that was good that's
right
mike mike gave a better alana answer
than alana did
i thought justin timberlake's i'm loving
it
pretty well that's not justin timberlake
i'm loving it
is justin timberlake right but that's
not who wrote it
that's probably true he probably did not
write it
um i don't i'm just letting this all
play out this song is by justin
timberlake
i'm loving it i'm loving it it's just
the mcdonald's
pusha t wrote the song yeah there you go
do you know who wrote like um like a
good neighbor
state farm is there that i've never
heard of that in my life so i've never
heard that
really you deserve a break today was the
original mcdonald's one do you deserve a
break today
at mcdonald's ever heard that one oh
thank heaven
didn't make it to australia in the uk
though foreign
mcdonald's dad's like come to make his
mate
get yourself a pig
um no barry manilow wrote like state
farms 7-eleven
mcdonald's he like wrote all of these
jingles
um and then the the guys from deep blue
something i think or
some some 90s band wrote oh thank heaven
uh for 7-eleven and made like a
gajillion dollars well you know who
wrote
uh the uh flintstones vitamins
remember that like yeah what 10 million
strong or whatever it ends with a little
kid going
growing you know who wrote that randy
newman
you wish
that was written by the halo composer
marty o'donnell before he
got into games and the and growing is
his daughter
singing in the original ad shut up
denise try to make a song oh do you guys
like that
yeah we use the girl she's free i met
marty once and i complimented him on a
specific track in halo that i loved and
it was
the only track in the halo soundtrack
that he didn't write nailed it
i remember a a friend of mine did the
same thing with
the the movie liar liar that was one
where james newton howard was hired to
write the score and then got another job
and basically
had to leave and goes there's a composer
john debney who
uh i think could take over very well so
they kept
james's main theme and john adopted that
and wrote the rest of the score
and uh i have a friend who once met john
and first thing out of his mouth was i
love your theme to liar liar
so much and it's like yeah well
thanks oh you do no candidates for my
runner-up most iconic piece of film
music of all time
i i said 2001 but that doesn't really
count because that's absolutely does not
count it was not licensed
you're just wrong go ahead and kick him
out for the uh yeah
i'm gonna take my claim specifically
that score
soundtrack is incredibly popular it is
it is
it is uh it's because it's good austin's
because it's really good i don't deny
that i feel like
star wars no no no no you could play
that on your keyboard
and you'd love it
i mean that's it it's rameen jawadi who
would have thought that that
uh his pacific rim score would be damn
near as popular as his game of thrones
score
star wars is not a bad uh is not a bad
guess but i think this
wins the reason the reason i would put
this above
in in the league of uh jaws there's two
criteria that come to mind for me number
one
is it is such a small little thing
literally
two notes you can boil it down to
something so tiny
right and still get it and on top of
that it's so ingrained in the culture
that even little kids who have never
even seen jaws know what that means
and this is true for the other one it
just means shock
and it means
everything i just said i love how troy's
just fully committed to this oh there he
is
i mean i did i did mute him i don't know
if he's aware of that
i
um i could also i could stop this video
but
let's see how long we can hold that uh
oh that ah
already already done so what is it
austin
it's it's literally basically just
that's the note it's all psycho
yeah you're right you know what that
means without having even
seen the movie and you only have to do
one note and it's literally boiled down
to something
three thank you troy it's actually a
whole it's actually a minute long just
playing one note for [ __ ] sake but
that's a compliment oh my god
okay case in point i played i played one
thing on the piano and you got it
yeah to me that that is that is uh
is that what you're saying the next
innovation is like half a note right
it's like yeah exactly someone reaching
for the keyboard that would be there
speaking of horror scores uh i did
google it and it turns out that you
cannot get
ptsd from something that is not real
it has to be considered to be a
traumatic event uh and an event cannot
be something that you
observe digitally or read or based upon
what you could be if
you could trick someone into thinking it
was real though
that's exactly like is that just a
clinical definition that they won't
definitely i'm just saying from like a
futuristic holodecky
nonsense perspective no i think i think
in vr you probably could if you if you
tricked someone but
i guess the event is more than expensive
commentary yeah here's here's some like
like anecdotal stuff like i
i know people and i even had this thing
where i saw something in a theater
oh you can think about maybe even your
own life but definitely
i'm sure you've heard a story of someone
saying oh my god i have a thing about
spiders because when i was a kid
i saw right blank or i just you know i
watched raiders a lot of stark and i saw
snakes i just can't deal with that
that i'm not saying that that's clinical
post-traumatic stress disorder
but that is that is a level of
post yeah that came from fiction fear
that came from something that
your mind knows isn't real but you still
associated
with that you're like i can't i don't do
yeah like how many people have said i
saw it when i was nine years old and and
uh
i'm just like clowns clowns are just
getting into clowns done forever
well isn't that phobia as well like
again like like the shark killing thing
wasn't there a specific spike in that as
a phobia among children because of that
movie right they literally tracked
clowns one culturally as a obviously
kids have always been afraid of various
things but like culturally clowns as a
key
corephobia specifically ties into that
into the
tim curry tv movie i'm sure i again read
that somewhere
i think there's that i also remember um
outbreak the movie outbreak with dustin
hoffman
yeah from france the
the fact
as marcel you mean is it marcel is it
marcelo
this is like a famous monkey sorry was
that from seinfeld too i have no idea
i lived the 90s i didn't watch the shows
in the 90s
i'd have to watch tv about it i was a
sitcom
um the the they even build their
um like their marketing campaign is like
this will do for theaters what
jaws did for the ocean and because
there's a scene in
outbreak where someone who's sick goes
to the theater and sneezes
and everybody that's in the theater ends
up get catching this
this deadly disease and i remember when
that happened
just the the factor of what was
happening on screen people that they
were like i can't and people
left the theater and it really did have
a direct
impact well they take um any kind of
plane crashes out of movies that you see
on planes
yeah i was in a plane and they didn't do
that with a movie
which one and i was freaked out by it
like oh what was it it was something
dark knight rises they hadn't done that
for me one time
there was yeah there was one like i'm i
can't remember what it was but i
remember being genuinely like
really we're leaving that makes me wanna
makes me wanna watch this movie alive
where it's like i don't understand the
premise of this movie at all
why are they there i think it's always
so funny when you watch a movie with a
sex scene
and there's like a three-year-old child
next time
you don't want to look affected but then
you look like
sociopathic if there's just like two
people just
screaming my kids that's what it looks
like
i watched like almost a whole season of
big little lies it's the name of the
show and uh
nicole kidman is her character is in an
abusive relationship
and sometimes that abusive relationship
is like extremely sexual
i was watching that show and there's a
little girl sitting next to me the whole
flight
and every time i'm like [ __ ] and i
would try to hide it from her
but then because i was obviously hiding
it she got extra curious
and at one point was like what are you
hiding i was like
this woman's getting she's in a very bad
relationship but she needs to get out
i was so annoyed by it she grew up
and she's australian so i have to watch
it
you don't know it's not that's right i
can't turn it up there's a lot legally
required
feed you to a dingo if you turn off the
cold i think i was flying home
as well
like a heavily sensor like flying in a
heavily set between
heavily censored countries is really
interesting because you have like i
watched one movie and it was like
literally any like there were like shots
i think it was there was a beach scene
people in bikinis and they were blurred
from like the chin downwards just an
entire or whenever
whatever they were shown in bikinis or
shows you know i was in bahrain
and we were doing it became a joke we
would like text each other back and
forth and go
see if you can google this it was like
how off could you guys like okay what if
we did
it was just like what combination could
you somehow trick the algorithm of the
entire country go don't look at porn
oh my god i would absolutely go for like
a hunt to see if i could find
boobs and you just big bahongas nope not
allowed you just look for anything
that'd be amazing it became
such a great little joke you're like
because you would see like the little
wheel go
maybe no this has been blocked by this
that's probably that's probably the most
valuable thing
tourists bring to the country at that
point where they're like search engines
there's all this new there's all this
new traffic on odd novel things and
they're like oh
good news
[ __ ] humanity man it's like the worst
i uh i watched two billboards on a
flight and
um they censored every single swear word
in that movie which i absolutely love
that movie
um no no no no they replaced the words
so there was one where they were like i
love your car
and i was like she loves his car why is
that
relevant in this scene and then i
realized like it was a vaguely sexual
scene and i was like
oh but the whole scene every sexual word
she says was like car
pants
it was an absolutely incredible way to
watch that rather serious film
oh and my first time watching it three
billboards outside of ebbing missouri
yeah no sure about prequel two okay
oh sorry yeah three bubbles sorry and i
was like two billboards
no no i was doing part of the billboard
cinematic universe
i watched here's a great left turn i
watched tennant
i think oh that's that's how it feels
how i was actually very impressed with
the
censorship like cutting in and out that
was very uh
chase chevy chase and spies like art
outlet yeah we'll get back to you
watching turn it but i did i did tell my
audience that i would talk to you about
this that um
you know playing the medium i just
i just felt like you're a bit clingy and
that we maybe need to have more
boundaries in our friendship
yeah not a good relationship it was just
like a bit a bit much
i felt like you wanted to wear my skin
and i was like troy can you please calm
down here
this do we need to do the podcast
bi-weekly
was your voice not like heavily edited
no are you serious nope that's actually
his natural voice
yeah that's really actually sounds like
about the character and it was like what
do you is like first of all we don't
want it to be
we want it to be androgynous we want it
to be you know
presenting is non-binary because it's
not about being a male
or a female it's a it's an entity yeah
it's so they really yeah all references
of he
or she are removed from that because of
when you play the game you understand
where the entity came from
and how it can it was like can you move
and we talked about maybe doing
um a layer and actually having two
actors do it to where there's like a
male and a female they're like but then
we have both represented and that's not
what we're going for it's almost like
can you do this androgynous
thing it was like let's find out what it
looks like we spent a whole
session just finding it and they were
really cool about
like that's it's coming across too
creature-ish and everything
so we would pull it back but really by
and large we kind of kept the print
and and just moved through it and they
just let me go
and as opposed to taking it line by line
it was it was more about put me in the
space and see environmentally what's
happening and what are we trying to
what's the intention here and it was a
really cool chat it's one of those gigs
where
i walked in i was like yeah i can do
that
i think i can can i do that and
it was when you're on and they're like
okay
we hired you do do the thing i was like
[ __ ]
how what does this look like and you
just kind of close your eyes and do it
but it it
um they wanted specifically to not do
like all of the tricks of like you know
everything that you normally use to to
create creepy voices they're like we
don't do that
so it's like we'll put you spatially in
a place and so we'll add some reverb and
stuff and maybe do a little eq
but by and large that like we want it to
be as organic as possible i said with
such confidence no of course these
voices edited who are we kidding
of course it is wow that's crazy i don't
want to kick the team down because
they're like you have no idea the amount
of post-processing we did but sure
they specifically wanted to to not have
it
come across that way so it's but yeah i
was even thinking as like
when when i first heard it for the first
time i was like oh i thought you guys
were like [ __ ] with this and they're
like
no we wanted this to believe that this
came out of an organic being
it's very unsettling and uh
someone when i was streaming it uh made
the comment of like why would you hire
an actor like troy baker and then make
him change his voice like that and he
was like well because they're not hiring
him for his voice they're hiring him for
this creepy as hell performance it's the
way you make troy act yeah but he's got
such a beautiful voice you know why
would you make him
that but it's it's very good it raises
the question i like today's show is
there
uh is there ever have you ever played a
character that you feel like
never mind the writing for them but just
physically sounds you feel like you j
you didn't really put anything
on vocally it just sounds like you
straight on yeah i think
delson is pretty close to me reece is
really close to me like boca sort of is
i was gonna say booker also different
that booker's
to me booker was and and ken and i
specifically worked it was like there's
a manner of speaking to him there's a
natural rhythm to speaking to him and
there's a there's a
quality that that to me was of character
um that that isn't um
me but by and large was just kind of
like just go
just just see what happens that that
really happened with with reese and
borderlands because
nick and pierre the the two writers were
just like don't do it don't act
just just go jonesy fortnite
is 100 me and we worked real hard
because at first they were like this is
what we wanted to be and then we got to
these
audio logs and it was like
we don't have any animation don't worry
about just go and i was like i'm just
gonna
[ __ ] with them and we just went
and they were like now we found the
character so
jonesy is very is just it's just me
have you ever relatedly then have you
ever had a character that you
really wanted to push somewhere
and they walked it back through feedback
until it eventually was essentially you
talking
like you've ever been kind of iterated
into how did you know i immediately
looked at you mike
i just i'm a smiling guy i'm a smiling
guy
i'm a happy guy yes
mike bithell i was like it ain't hex
what yeah
hex is not your you speaking oh but as
far as like just
like we ended up but like as far as like
i want to go here with it and
mike had such so much more of a global
understanding of the character and the
story and where he needed to fit in
there's like
no man that's not i don't this guy needs
to belong here
not here and you're trying to put him
here because you think this would be
cool but i need you to trust me
that this is where the guy is yeah i
guess it was tricky
specifically because we had uh we had
such an established world we had the
cast as well
from the movie so like lance and ian
like we knew what they were doing and we
knew
i knew what the other voices in that
room were and yeah you
and that's something you know troy
absolutely gets not all actors do get
that kind of collaboration
that kind of yes fighting your corner
but also being part of a
ensemble and kind of that's something
that you know
different actors are better and worse
albert troy definitely gets
i like this show a lot today it's a
great show it's a great episode
well i'm yeah i'm just i'm i'm i'm
curious because i've experienced
the closest analogy to that musically a
bunch of times where
you start off with an idea that feels
you know bold and and unique and
whatever else and then
troy goes can you just do these notes
and then mike's like stop it
yeah it's like just chill the [ __ ] out
almost always well that's the thing
almost always with good reason
it it gets into a place but but there
are definitely been times where you're
like
i don't really recognize myself anymore
in this music because
it's been iterated to such a degree uh
that that all the things i was bringing
to it feel kind of lost and now my job
is to provide the score that my
collaborator is looking for
so that happens sometimes um
and and it's you know fair enough
fortunately it doesn't happen
the majority of the times but there's
but that's why i was curious if there's
kind of the quasi
even though in a way what i'm describing
is the opposite of that where you feel
like you built a thing and all that's
left is you
uh just talking and how that might be
intrinsically less interesting i mean
bruce at avengers
was was really just and that was shauna
skye going
you don't have to be mark ruffalo you
don't have to be anybody else i really
just want to see what you
bring to this role i felt like he was
troy but sad
there's a lot of that that's destroyed
stops recording i can't it's man it's
really interesting look
i i i today's been an interesting week
because there's there's been like
that sounds like tenant talk right there
today has been an interesting week
that's actually more like thank you guys
that's some time dilation talk so i
wrong nolan movie sorry no i just
continue
this has been this has been a week of
like um i
it's not often that i i get put into a
place where it's like hey
um we're really gonna stretch you and do
you you say that you want these kind of
opportunities and you say you want this
but do you really think you can do this
and so i find myself squarely in the
middle of it and
there's a quote by daenerys like i hate
auditioning because if i had to audition
still i probably wouldn't work
because he just no one's good at
auditioning it's the worst
part of the job it isn't the job by the
way auditioning is not the job
the job is the job auditioning is just
sometimes what you have to do
and so i've had to do things this week
where it's like remember
that there's still these hoops you have
to jump through and
i jump through those hoops and it's it's
um
it's so funny because i i walked into it
thinking that i had to
dress up and literally and and
create this whole thing and i i got to
the other side i was like
man i do all this stuff that i say don't
do
and i what it ended up happening is the
director was like i just want to see you
i don't i don't i just need to see what
you do and how you move in this space
and how you
not interpret this character but just
let me just see you for a second
and i was like oh man i forgot about
that so i think that there's
there's a um i i am just like any other
actor
all of us here where there's a
a sense that i want to build this thing
up so that i feel like i've accomplished
something or that i've moved the needle
forward or that people go wow
that's impressive but at the end of the
day every person that's on this right
now is inherently
really good at what they do and what you
naturally just bring to it
is enough you don't have to
write the score to end all scores or
create the game or write the game or
code the game
um or write the [ __ ] out of a scene it's
just you have a sensibility you got the
gig
your life is your gig and you got it so
just do that and that is enough
i i don't know that i'm with you on that
oh i
think that depends on the on the field
since got a really good idea for a one
note
but he completely you're like nah that's
all [ __ ]
no no i i think generally i would agree
but i do know that's a i
don't even feel like that's a
professional thing i think that that's a
personality type thing like i know
people who always feel like they have to
do
way more than they do um to the extent
that it can actually lessen their
their intent like it becomes worse
because you tried to do too much please
just
just reign it back and to the to the
note of like what austin's original
question was
uh it was an original question i don't
even know really
i think it had something to do with
jumping on trains
about uh you know being worked back um
we have the opposite issue of that when
i worked in games media because i did do
a lot of editing like inside gaming i
did so
much editing um of everyone's writing
and i did the same thing in ign um
and and that's a really difficult game
when it's with the journalism style of
writing of
not making the edits that i want to make
because i want it to read like i wrote
it um and i've worked with editors who
edit you way too much and i'm like okay
i
i get that you don't like this word but
you don't like this word because you
don't like this word
it's not an issue with the word on a
global scale and then i felt like with a
certain editor
that i had started to write for them i
was like i know which things they like
and don't like so i'm going to write for
them instead of writing for the audience
and it can become this like really
negative thing where you feel like
you're actually just writing for one
person you're not writing as yourself
anymore you're not writing for an
audience anymore
and i think when editing other people's
work where writing is concerned that's a
really difficult game to play to be like
do i like this
is this just me or does this actually
make the sentence clearer
and it you can lose someone's voice so
easily and so quickly
what you're sorry what you're describing
is i think one of the single most
common challenges for uh
composition like students
when because when i i got a comp you
know
classically oriented composition degree
which means that you know it's kind of
the conservatory style
model where you have these professors
that
are you you end up with a private
composition teacher where each week you
bring them your music and they offer
feedback and the problem is that the the
old stereotype of
like t you know the the ranks of
teachers is populated by
washed out professional failures i've
always hated that because
teaching is such a um a crucial part of
our society and it's something that i've
i've always enjoyed doing i don't know
if i'm any good at it but it's something
i enjoy doing and i've had some
phenomenal teachers
but boy have i also had a few that
struggled with exactly what you're
describing where
you know like let's say i want to write
a a simple a simple little
piece you know it's just like you know
here isn't that nice right
yeah and and then i had this one i was a
little disappointed austin i was a
little disappointed well you're a lot
like my professor then because
the uh too simple the the teacher that i
had he had the double whammy of being
very frustrated with his own career and
sort of took it out
through his teaching but on top of that
his father had been a pretty successful
composer so he had the
extra bit of bitterness baked in as well
and so i remember i would play him
some of the music i was writing and and
he would basically say you know he would
do things like this where it's like
what if it was you know his head would
come off
[Music]
and uh point being is that as he would
be like what if it was more like that
and i and it's sort of like why and it's
because that's what i like and if i were
writing it that's what it would be
he wouldn't say that but that's what he
meant it was i don't
know how to make your piece interesting
but i know how to make it sound like one
of mine
which of course we're not good uh and so
it's a really
real problem with the education system
it really likes questions
like you know i have that i run into
that all the time with my team i have to
work so hard to like make them
especially with junior people like to
make them
unlearn that they just have to give me
exactly what i want it's like you have
been hired because you're better than me
at what you do
please you know stop you know trying
just to give me what i want and then
something
that's often people come into the
industry with that's writers is uh by
the whole like
there's there's a uh a guy then working
with on a show a brilliant writer uh
ashley miller
and i was like how do you divorce
yourself from the read that you
wrote the read that happened in your
head when you wrote the line in the
scene that you wrote
the reason why you're like oh and he
looks out the window and he turns and he
says
and you're like [ __ ] this is going to be
awesome how do you
it compels you to write it how do you
divorce yourself from that version when
the actor comes in
and it's totally different he was like i
understand that my job is to give you
something that you can make better
and i remember the first director that i
worked with
big big first big movie that i was on
first scene
big like two pay two or three page
monologue
and i have like a couple of lines
and i'm just sitting there watching
steve's on
wax loquacious and he goes
we get done with the first scene or we
got like the first take
and the director is simon winsters and
ozzy goes pi
which is my character's name it's a
great script i was like yes
yes sir he goes don't make it better
and i went okay
and it was his first note to me and
there's there's i think two different
styles where it's like
hey man i need you to do there's a
reason why i want you to do this
specifically
i need you to hit your mark exactly
because i know the i want that blade
runner lighting to hit you right here
and i need you to trust me versus
someone going
i'm going to interpret your writing and
i'm going to put it through my lens and
hopefully together
we make something that's better than
both of our perspectives i don't know
which is better
i really don't i think a skill director
can oscillate i think a skill director
knows when he has to get you on the mark
and knows when he has to get you
more of his collaborator to move between
the move between
in my head and i guess this is like just
the aaa
space i don't know if this probably
wouldn't work for mike but
if i'm writing a line that someone is
going to read
uh that's like in my head such a
separate process
i'm like i'm not gonna be there i did my
part the rest of it is on everyone else
so i'm not even really gonna connect
those two things i had the opposite
experience to like troy in a way that
the first kind of
the first couple of things i directed i
tried i remember
was it danny it might have been daddy on
thomas was alone like
i remember he read a line and then i
tried to like
give him a read and he didn't like that
and that was the moment where i was like
oh okay i'm never doing that again in my
career
daddy's a lovely bloke but like he made
it he he let me know that
no but then he what was weird was then
later on because we'd open that door he
did ask me for some reads on other
things but it was definitely like i
realized that that's a tension point and
that's a
that's something you you build that
respect with an actor like when i'm
directing i will
often be quite quiet early on and just
let the actor figure out what they want
to do and then you can kind of approach
them and that's
i think a lot of video game uh direction
for voice actors is what what troy
alluded to earlier is to kind of
do me three reads of each of these lines
and i don't think that's a good way to
get to
the performance i think often i like to
just run scenes or
something that drives me nuts some
actors want the three
the three readers that's the way i've
done it for everything that i've done
that's been animated
um and and part of what i hate about
that is that i don't know which ones
they're gonna pick so being consistent i
find difficult i'm like but if what was
the tone of the previous one that you're
going to be consistent right that's the
problem you're trying to
how do i stick with someone should ask
there's that's a question you should ask
okay where are we liking did you like
the a the b or the c is like well we're
gonna go with the b with the previous
it's like okay
this this line feeds off of that right
so we need to match this
this b needs to be this b you can tell
when
you can tell when the actor didn't ask
that question especially on giant rpgs
where they just had to get through 20
million lines and
within one like adjacent sentences of a
monologue
the emotions are jumping up and down in
the rhythm and everything and
you're like what that's the actor's
fault for the actors
well i think the best voice acting
there's a responsibility that look the
actor was given the job
to shepherd that character through that
role
um but you can also allow for the
scenario where the actor did you know
the a
the b the a the b and they choose a of
one and b of the other
after the actor's gone the actors
absolutely troy you're you're arguing
that they can
you can kind of you're you're almost the
first editor of your performance right
you're
making sure you're giving the bad
version the final edit it's not my job
to fix their game
right it's not my job to come in and fix
their script fix their story fix their
character what i can do
is lend my performance to it or lend my
perspective and together
i i'm going to quote austin right now
and i even use this yesterday
my job or the my goal is not the end
result my what i'm selling is the
process by how together will get there
that's that's what i do it's like
giving a great performance like no no
that's not what we're gonna do the end
result could be the performance but what
i wanna
what i'm why you hire me is to to make
me an ad hoc partner in this and we're
gonna do this together
but you the actor the writer whoever is
not responsible for the locked
picture and the end result what you are
responsible for is going
hey ma'am wouldn't be doing my job if i
didn't say
i need i need to know these are the
things that i need to know there's some
people that don't need to know that
i think that there's a responsibility to
the consistency and the continuity of
the character to be able to go
did you go with a b or c what are you
leaning towards well we don't know
what are you feeling you're going to go
with there's one that that tickled your
taint a little bit and made you stand up
and
what what what which one did you want to
go with as far as like standard
metric for evaluation
from the project to sexual harassment
every time he's in more games than we
realize you just got to eat
fire the goddamn tape tickled
the toys there was there was a session
and there was a there was a very
established actor
and um
the director gave him a line read and
the director said i'm so sorry i'm so
sorry to give you the line read it
doesn't reflect on you
and without even looking up the actor
just went oh i'm
fully aware that it doesn't reflect on
me
wow and that's the truth
yeah and then the doctor was troy banker
he slapped him troy tickle taint taint
the taint tickler
baker um the truth is is that it doesn't
reflect on the actor it does reflect on
the director if the director the only
way they can go
is yeah just i'm going to use this cheat
that's fine if you do there's like would
you please forgive me and allow me i'm
i'm not able to articulate
exactly what it is but this is what i'm
hearing would you mind giving this to me
just so i can hear it
sure man absolutely but to go say it
like this is exactly what austin's
saying which is like
i don't know what your music is but i'm
going to make my music like this this is
what i would have written there's
there's
there's such better more constructive
ways
than just do it like that i've watched
troy direct and seen some of those
in action of these strategies of like i
needed to have a certain rhythm so maybe
it's about
can we just add some energy can we do
this and it's always about putting
tools in the hand of the actor to foster
that's what i was going to say foster
more energy the george lucas
thank you george lucas yeah uh i think
the the best director that i've worked
with and
you know it could be for a myriad of
reasons was um issa at rooster teeth who
uh helped me with the monster under my
bed short that i
uh voiced a character for and i feel
like what got me about that was a
her excitement like on the other side
she was like
i love that one and she would tell me
that whereas like sometimes they're just
like
b and then they just move on she was
just like so hyped about what i was
doing
but it was uh more than anything was
that she gave me an emotional read at
the beginning of each scene she was like
this scene
this would be how you would be feeling
like this is what the character is going
through and
i'm sure like a more experienced actor
would be more collaborative with
figuring out well why is this character
feeling this way
but as someone who is really new i found
that so so so helpful to be like okay
well this is probably the tone of this
and it's like okay would she be feeling
this for this reason and then it's like
a discussion at the start that made that
so easy and so comfortable from top to
bottom where some other things have just
been like no just say it
just say it like you're not reading it
okay judith weston and i know mike
you're short on time too so
i don't want to get too long
there we go judith weston is a great
resource for people who
either directors or actors um
she talks about how result-oriented
direction is the worst kind of direction
it's just the cheats like be angry
well what the [ __ ] does that mean my
angry could be
completely different we are all
different humans that we express our
anger sadness joy
everything in different ways so instead
being able to say
here's a challenge um don't let them
leave the room
and that's the goal it's like no matter
what if they walk away from the room
and there was even stuff that we did on
the shadow of war was like if i get to
you you lose
that's the that's the goal you and the
only way that you can stop me is with
your words
you know it's funny in that vein i
started watching this great documentary
of um i'm thinking on the name of it
it's called i think what we left
behind that's about um deep space nine
well we don't find yeah what we left
behind yeah and there's a great where
they're interviewing the woman i'm
blanking on her name the actress who
plays
the the original incarnation of dax
i could tell you like the name of any
actor who played one scene in star trek
it's a problem no it's very helpful in
this moment
she had a really tough time on that show
right she was really initially yeah the
the
the initial challenge that she had was
that her character is a symbiont which
means that it's like this
thousand-year-old
uh character that just happens to be
currently occupying
a girl in her 20s body but that it's uh
you know and
and what was brilliant about the premise
of the character is that
cisco had this long history of
friendship with the old man
prior what the guy who wrote the thong
song cisco yes
cisco cisco you're as bad as troy i'm
sorry that was my best story
followed me on twitter like i know and i
was like maybe i do have dumps like a
truck
maybe about matters maybe it matters
sorry i'll say it very sorry about that
when that one was fine
yeah go ahead uh but to that point about
the the
the the actor um like interpreting
lines and interpreting in the they said
that in the original
readings that you know um that uh avery
that
the character of cisco had he was being
so familiar and so congenial and he has
such a big presence and
he was also this veteran actor and she
was this young actress
and so she felt outmatched in the scene
and so every time he would be like
the whole joke is that she's this
attractive you know young 20s
and he always calls her old man because
that's how he knows the character
because to him he understands the body
is is transitive
or transient and so she he apparently
would really play it up in the initial
takes of you know kind of like old man
and
she basically said i i don't have the
confidence to
meet you where you are in that way but
so i don't know that i can sell that my
character
just hears that and accepts that and so
they like work together and
he became this much warmer you know like
oh
man like and and and it was a really
interesting way to
because i i'd watch the show and think
it's absolutely made to me it's peak
star trek and and but i'd never
seen this documentary uh until just the
last few days and watching and realizing
that there was a process between the two
of them to work out
that energy level just because of all
the extraneous factors
it blew my mind it really paid off too
because their dynamic is one of my
favorites of the many great dynamics
that that show has but
that there's something so beautiful
about packaging this old
respectful friendship through something
that doesn't look at all
like that as it turns out collaboration
good
title of this episode no i was thinking
about maybe calling it jumping on the
trains
jumping on trains i don't know i don't
know um hi everyone welcome to another
episode of play watch listen and i'm
alan a ps video game writer that's troy
baker video game actor
that is awesome witter wintry video game
composer and that is mike bithell
video game director um you're pointing
at your yourself stop
troy you know it's it's relative the
people see what i see
you're like and and that's mike bithell
didn't i do that i guess i technically
am pointing
and that's true
if troy wanted to talk about tenant if
you want to do that
did you see it very quickly i will tell
you
it's for the record i sent austin
as i'm off to to do i sent austin a text
i was like i just saw tennant
and i feel like halfway through mixing
the movie
christopher nolan just stopped and
thought to himself
damn this is a really good score i don't
know why he does
the audio mixes he does
[Music]
no it's not even that it's just like
all the time it's so weird but i was
like he just kept like pushing the
faders up like a 70s dj listening to
skynyrd for the first time just like
this [ __ ]
rocks you want to know you want to know
a funny true story of that happening
yes he fell asleep on the faders and
printed them
you're not it's not as far off as you
think um
one of my favorite human beings i've
ever been able to be close with in my
life kenny hall thank you
uh yeah just right there just right
behind troy baker
close runner up troy's halt bro um he
thought it was a true episode not a
kenny hall episode
it's true well for purposes of this
conversation we'll say that it was troy
but but just for the you know for the
viewers at home everybody will know what
we're talking about
kenny uh was a music editor worked on a
gazillion movies mostly with jerry
goldsmith but he worked with john
williams a few times
and uh and interestingly um
of of the few e.t was one of them and he
was parallel working
at the exact same time with goldsmith on
poltergeist so he was doing two
spielberg movies
right on top of each other and during
the
big bicycle fly in front of the moon
sequence you know this we've talked
about it here before this giant epic
thing williams recorded like a 12 minute
single take and all it's just madness so
kenny
is just so emotionally on board with
this this score he thinks it's the best
score he's ever heard in his life
and he's advocating for it in the in
those days at the final dub
you would have the dialogue there'd be
one big console you'd have the dialog
mixer the sound effects mixer and the
music editor
uh all kind of representing their
departments and sort of jockeying for
who
who's you know in in in dominant
position at a given moment and the and
the in the main dubber apparently
kept pushing the score down because it
was like well we can't hear the bicycle
wheels and we can't hear this and we
can't hear that
and kenny was like it's not about those
[ __ ] things it's
listen to this score and you think that
the bicycle wheel is going to be what
sells this scene
as williams is you know
[Music]
and so they're arguing and arguing and
kenny's
quite upset and you know this was all
proper analog gear you set the fader you
know if you're gonna do a print master
that's you know it's like it's it's not
digital of
just open up pro tools click it and you
can change it on the fly and whatnot
it's all pretty delicate
so they argue and argue and argue then
spielberg comes in and says show me the
scene
and right as they hit play kenny just
goes boom and hits the fader and
yanks the score into the stratosphere
and then
it was too late to change anything they
hit play cnn spielberg has tears coming
down and goes don't change a thing
and the guy just look and it's like
kenny outflanked him
and uh and so it it shipped that way and
john williams won another oscar
wow so yeah i i loved that i love that
kenny basically just
he went with the nuclear option what i
said earlier
collaboration may be bad that didn't
happen that happens
picturesque shot of a boy and an alien
going across a
silvery you know moon not in the middle
of
dialogue expositional dialogue that's
helping establish the world in the
states no but there are true
it's different from nolan but there are
there are lines in the scene that are
also getting
they're getting bludgeoned um you know
there are you know it's obviously
incidental
you know it's go faster and that kind of
stuff but like it's it's
the idea was just let the score uh
sell this and yeah the mixer is not e.t
i i and i told austin this you need i
wish that nolan would go back
and make smaller movies like
not just memento like memento was you
see
that was great that's exactly what i
said it was like go watch following
and you look at this guy and go holy
[ __ ] he's a great filmmaker
and he's not not just like a great
filmmaker he that guy was just being
like hey here's more limits here's some
more limits here's some more lemons
you have no budget you have no time
all you have to work with is splits of
her 16 millimeter film
you have no locations your actors
decided to [ __ ]
shave or or change their appearance
halfway through
shooting write it he just dealt with all
of these things and he made a great
truly hitchcockian thriller
shot in black and white and they did it
in like
six weeks but they shot it over weekends
it's [ __ ] insane for
no i love going back money finding those
films i like brick
as well right for ryan johnson like
similarly excellent early work yeah
it's and then all of a sudden it's like
the sophomore project like
that first coldplay record is i mean
arguably russian blood of the head is is
a better album but like the songwriting
of parachute i don't care what you think
about coldplay they're [ __ ] great
dude they're
great songwriters but like if it's chris
martin especially
but if you just that the the stuff that
was written from desperation it's a
place that i hope i don't ever lose it's
like
and i get to feel that again this week
where it's like hey remember what it was
like
to like have an audition that you really
want the role
this is perfect i don't [ __ ] know if
i'll get this or not you've perfectly
encapsulated why i disagreed with your
earlier comment when you said you know
you got the job so you're you're you're
probably good enough it doesn't need to
be the
be-all end-all score you've ever written
or performance and
and yet i wouldn't have gotten the job
if
at some point in the past i didn't put
everything that i had into the prior
works that maybe got through this door
that isn't that i don't want to lose
that ever but also desperately
essentially those desperate works were
also better right i'm the guy and the
guy made thomas was alone which demo
available now on switch
but it's but it is that thing of early
on i got it in there i knew i would
that but that that like i look at thomas
was alone often and go
was that like the best thing i'll ever
make like is that like
if you allow it to be i think yes but
what i'm saying is
that character that i'm auditioning for
or having a meeting about
or the character that i'm playing lives
agnostic of my desperation for what i
needed to be and
even the character even exists outside
of what the director with the writer
with the publisher
with the cinematographer what the
animator what the character doesn't care
how you feel
it doesn't give a [ __ ] and that's the
problem is that's what i'm saying is
like
have all your passions and that goes
into your preparation
that goes into all the work that you do
but the second that that light is on
or those cameras are rolling you go
you go away but that's i feel like
that's a distinction between process
and motivation like you're you're
basically saying don't get
so fixated on in the moment on how do i
make
every last little piece of what i'm
doing the greatest thing that has ever
happened and you're saying that's
noise in the moment when you're you know
in the line of fire and the mics are on
and all that
that's just noise that's going to cloud
up what you're doing you know that's
that's when you
when you hear the hesitation you know in
a in a performer you know when when
something
creeps into their mind as a musician or
an actor or whoever
you can feel their brain suddenly split
in two different places at once that's
different though
than i want to make this everything
if i die tomorrow this thing i'm doing
today
is a worthy last thing for me to have
done in this lifetime
and maybe that just for you is all in
the preparation in my case
you know i i mixed a score two weeks ago
and i could have delivered it and yet
i'm like
you know what i i have the time i'm i'm
doing two more weeks on these mixes
because i know it can be better
i do not envy the live performer i do
not envy the person like troy who has to
show up in the moment and deliver
i like the job where i get to have a bad
day i get it endlessly
like we could spend a couple of weeks
perfect example is where we were talking
about um
again this writer and showrunner that
i'm working with ashley miller
he goes some of the you know
he we were doing a writer's room and he
said ask everybody if i if i asked each
of you to tell me what the plot of star
wars is
i would get as many different views or
different opinions as there are people
in this room he goes what you would and
you would be hard-pressed to tell me the
plot of star wars without telling me
about a moment
a line or a feeling that you got when
you
watch star wars for the first time and
he said in most of the lines that you
would quote
wouldn't even be from star wars they'd
be from empire i love you
i know empire you're my uh i'm your
father
empire all of those are from empire i
don't think i'm your father is a star
wars line
i am your father i'm your father i'm
your father i'm your father
so what he was saying was that um and
especially the
the um i love you i know was an
ad-libbed line
and he goes because in the script i love
you i love you too and i said what i
love about that is you watch harrison
ford and there's an excitement about him
when he says
i know when he knows what he's about to
do is off script
and it comes up so confidently but still
there's like
i have no idea what's gonna happen on
the other side i always read it as
compassion
i always read it as him saying to her
we've just spent the last two hours only
doing one thing which is fighting
and i want you to know that i i
understood it and not only that but
everything that you've said everything
that you've done i know that you love me
i know it i don't know i said i said
that to a dude once and it was just
because i knew he had a crush on me
i know that's that's terrible but but
what i
thought when i was taking the whole seed
flushed before drunken
nightclub he was like i love you and i
was like i know
do you think i'm an idiot thank you and
then one second later the game just shot
up from below you alana you were frozen
in carbonite
if you if you want to have a moment if
you want to add lip you want to go off
script you go i have an idea
because what harrison ford that the
trepidation and the nervousness is not
coming from his acting ability it's the
fact of i have no idea
that could been the longest day after so
many setups
so many turnarounds all the different
problems
maybe lunch was late everyone's tired
and you're gonna ask the entire cast and
crew
to wait and go one more time through the
scene
so that you can say i know if you do
if you make that choice it that's the
bar that's the standard
it better change the character and be
one of the most
quotable indelible lines from one of the
most successful franchises ever
but if it's not shut the [ __ ] up
and trust the director says or you move
on and this coming from me
who always thinks he has a better take
on him and always wants to change the
line
i just realized if i want to change the
line and go off script and
ad-lib and come up with some ideas i'm
asking everybody on that cast and crew
who may have to go to the bathroom who
just had a text
whatever that they need to wait because
my choice is more important than theirs
and if it is
then so be it but it better be ready to
change that character and change this
okay so troy yeah how did you like
tennant
[Laughter]
there it is better you've been waiting
you've been waiting longer than i was i
definitely didn't really want to say
that yeah
i don't i didn't people don't seem to
like it
it's a feat it's it's it's a it's an
accomplishment of cinematography and
filmmaking
kenneth brenna is uh just unlimited is
there anything he's bad
in to be honest he's just a brilliant
[ __ ] he's always good
he's bad in but he was great he directs
himself badly i think
did you watch the world must be peopled
did you watch dead again
i don't see that i think it's his first
thing that he ever directed
uh beautiful beautiful black and white
noir
thriller it's great part of it's black
and white sorry
uh i think he's a brilliant director i
think he's an amazing actor
i want to meet him he does a great
russian accent he is the best part of
the movie
um somebody needs to answer that girl's
call for help because i don't think
she's well
um reference to something in the movie
she's too thin like she doesn't oh you
mean the
the female protagonist okay
noted she doesn't look healthy
is the problem but still
he is in different things you can be
thin and still healthy
i look at me i mean i'm i'm a lanky dude
pretty lucky
but i i she just doesn't look healthy
okay
look i have to fight you on this one
because you're not a doctor
that's my heart i'm not a doctor not a
doctor at all
um all right actually you troy did a
full like body mask
can i can i repeat what alana said and
get credit for in the comments please
yeah [ __ ] nuts i love it when mike
says
come on i love it
so they do it like i said it first it's
a mandela effect
no mike bethel i remember
the other day someone was like well mike
said it more aggressively and i was like
well yeah i'm a woman
i don't know what you want me to ah um
okay i remember when mike bethel was a
woman
yeah he probably said that too i'm gonna
love it when mike says it so leaning
your head
we are on episode 49 which means next
week's episode
is a live episode for our 50th episode
um i have some new merch that i'm gonna
drop which i'm pretty excited about that
i will do
while we're live but i guess uh we
haven't spoken about the
time we know about it yeah you've seen
it you've seen so much it's a lot of
focus merch
it's just my face finally capitalizing
on uh
the face we should explore to the aliens
oh yeah
um jumping on trans probably tuesday
tuesday i mean i think that's that's the
window that
i'm always available on tuesday what can
i say yeah likewise
i'm gonna say it's gonna be tuesday
from 11 30 to 12 30.
is this a commitment to the wait i
thought it was 12 30. you're right it is
usually 12 30 1 30. 12 30 to 1 30 next
tuesday pacific
and if we change that i'll tweet it out
but that is the plan that we will do it
live
um on youtube so everyone can join in
for
another 10 episodes 50 episodes you guys
well we're almost
52 weeks we've made it longer than the
original
star galactica like that's like 10 years
that's five years of a monthly podcast
not 10 years
i can't count classic programming
podcast monthly it'll be fine
look at this guy look at this now look
at this who would have thought who would
have thought
um yeah this is what you're doing with
your friday night and we still haven't
figured out why people
don't move if they jump on trains and i
think that's what i have to do with this
[ __ ] episode
one division was good i got to watch one
division before he did this i'm happy oh
you bastard i haven't watched it
people seem to really like it i've also
not watched it yeah you should watch
this one no i just mean you haven't seen
this episode
up till this point and it has it is it
yeah i'm loving it
very curious it's really fun yeah justin
timberlake or
getting sued now john we've been
demonetized because of that whistle
let's see yes
yeah we got demonetized last week
because i started the episode with
the fish [ __ ] thing so you know if
it's justin timberlake that takes us
down this time it's not does it seem
quite real
did it really uh it got limited ads
because you can't have a swear word in
the like start of a video and i was like
i could take it out
i'm not going to take it out she's
committed to it
so funny does that mean that there were
less comments that were like
there's 4 000 ads in this one well
yeah the problem with that is that
youtube automates ads when you upload
something and because i always upload
the show like it's never scheduled it's
always just immediately uploaded when
it's done
youtube populates it with the ads
wherever it wants and as many as it
wants and you can't manually edit that
immediately so i will like have to go
away for an hour and then it has a
thousand ads by the time i get back
which is the time that i can manually
edit the amount of ads that are in it
it's very simple to explicitly state
that we are not
the reason why you were but we're fine
with doing the
the no monetization thing is because
we're we're not doing this for money
like there's no oh yeah no they're not
being paid no the cost of the show
doesn't even cover the cost of hosting
it it's free
or the other way around the ads don't
even cover the cost of hosting and
editing the show every month
so the show that's what it's intended to
go towards to even have those ads is pay
for the show but it doesn't cover it
and here i was just assuming that your
background was a subtle uh suggestion of
the kingdom you've purchased by
embezzling our ad money
that's right profiting greatly off of
this show
and the match told proceeds go to
charities so you know we're really out
here being good capitalists
it's great good capitalist
all right we will see you for our live
episode next week everyone